ATS the soldier is in the air so no
wonder the ninth season of American
Horror Story is taking place smack dab
in the middle of that decade but how
will a HS 1984 fit into the show's
ever-expanding canon here's everything
we know so far
leave it to AHS co-creator Ryan Murphy
the blend eighties camp with the
menacing undertones of a slasher film
and all said to the kickee tune of dan
Hartman's I can dream about you back in
july 2019 Murphy made the official cast
announcement on Instagram through a
series of stylish videos staged to look
like camera tests as you can see
everyone is tagged out and their most
ill-advised eighties fashions hard to
say whether this is what the cast will
actually look like throughout the coming
season they could just be toying with
out expectations here meanwhile the
official teaser trailers heavily draw
from slasher film archetypes and
scenarios in one Caesar we see a truck
full of youngsters on the way to camp
redwood they're partying so hard they
failed to see the word but we're screwed
in red paint on the back of the camp
redwood sign meanwhile the master man
with a knife is hiding in the
undercarriage this guy really gets
around
he later jumps out of a lake in order to
stop a bikini clad woman basically a
straight-up homage to the first Friday
the 13th in another teaser a young woman
is chased through the dark woods she
hides in a cabin and soon enough a knife
comes through the door yet another
teaser features a group of camp
counselors settling into their bunks and
when the cabin door closes
another teaser demonstrates a danger of
skinny-dipping and this teaser is an ode
to the simple pleasures like listening
to your Walkman and getting brutally
murdered our theory this season is going
to be a whole lot of fun
as with previous seasons of American
Horror Story Ryan Murphy has assembled a
mix of new and returning cast members to
play all new characters this time in
1984 returning stars include Cody Fern
Billie lourd Emma Roberts Leslie
Grossman and the decidedly creepy John
Carroll Lynch were particularly loving
Cody fern as an 80s style preppy dude
especially since he looks a bit like
James Spader and pretty and pink
newcomers include Olympic skier Gus
Kenworthy Glee alum Matthew Morrison
Angelica Ross from the hit series pose
dear white people's to run Horton and
dr. a musician zach via unfortunately
AHS 1984 we'll be losing some of the
series most beloved cast members - you
know how that goes of course Jessica
Lange left the show as a regular player
after the fourth season freak show and
now two more regulars are following in
her footsteps
sadly Evan Peters won't be returning the
season due to the intensity of his roles
in both American Horror Story and Ryan
Murphy's pose he decided to take a break
meanwhile Sarah Paulsen won't be
returning to the show in any significant
role although deadline reports we can
expect to see her at some point in the
season with any luck she'll pop up in a
cameo like Lange did in season 8 in the
upcoming season of AHS a tease the
soldier is clearly in full bloom so it
might be worth revisiting some seminal
horror films from 1984 just in case Ryan
Murphy has decided to use them for
inspiration 1984 was a big year for the
horror genre after all that was the year
of Nightmare on Elm Street was released
nobody in the hallway then there was
Friday the 13th the final chapter and
who can forget children of the corn also
worth noting firestarter came out in
1984 and so did Brian De Palma's can be
psychological thriller body double both
films certainly aligned with Murphy's
unique brand of horror
then again longtime AHS executive
producer Tom mania reminds us to expect
the unexpected The Wrap as to whether
this season would be revisiting 80s
horror films and he replied generally
Ryan is the head of the zeitgeist as
opposed to following it so what I would
say is that this has been an area that
Ryan has talked about since I've known
him and it's just a real sweet spot for
him and I think it was time for him to
do it so what's the story
it looks like AHS 1984 is going to be a
beautiful gory and funny homage to the
slasher films of the 80s but this is a
Ryan Murphy production so you can
probably expect some social and
political subtext too after all the year
1984 corresponds to George Orwell's
Sisto peein novel of the same name just
saying one more thing the use of the
motels classic singles suddenly last
summer in the camp redwood teaser could
be a clue to the plotline after all
suddenly last summer is a classic 1958
play written by Tennessee Williams it
was later adapted into a film starring
Elizabeth Taylor the story involves a
woman named Catherine who's traumatized
after witnessing her cousin's death her
aren't played by Katharine Hepburn
attempts to keep her son's death a
secret by lobotomizing her niece it's
some what do you mother dramatic stuff
it also covers subject matter that's up
this series Ali and Lee wouldn't be at
all surprised if the show pays homage to
suddenly last summer in AHS 1984 the
ninth season of American Horror Story
premieres on September 18 to 2019 at
10:00 p.m. Eastern Time the season will
have a 10 episode run with the seventh
episode set to air on October 30th which
just so happens to be Halloween Eve help
terribly apropos check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite TV shows
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]